الالاف ممن دفعتهم اصوات الرصاص في اقليم
دارفور غربيه السودان وصلوا الى جنوب
السودان غالبيتهم من النساء والاطفال حيث
يعيشون اوضاء ميشيه صعبه
مع الناس بس ما عارفين زول نهائي في البلد
[موسيقى]
معروف راقدين والله في التراب بانين اتياب
ما في حاجه
الفارونه لا تنقطع قصصهم عن العالقين بين
الايران الاشتباكات حيث فقدت الكثير من
الاسر اقرب اهلها لم يعرف مصيرهم فاصبحوا
في ايداد الموتى او المفقودين
هل يندعيشين السيم على الناس قاعدين ذاته
وين احنا مسكين انت حاليا
اخواني بعدين في المدرسه واحد انا
الطعام هو واحد من اكثر الصعوبات التي
تواجه الالاف من الفارينه الموجودين هنا
في هذا المكان وسط غياب تام لاي مساعدات
انسانيه لهم انا تعبانين وجينا
الفجر كلهم
الحمراء
هو في ظل نقص الطعام وتزايد اعداد الفارين
يوميا تزداد المخاوف من عدم التزام
الاطراف المتحاربه بوقف دائم لاطلاق النار
مبيوتشر اللغه العربيه شمال بحر الغزال
جنوب السودان
لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا على يوتيوب
الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل جرس
التنبيهات